krieg in syrien keine flüchtlingsboote
im mittelmeer raketenstart in nordkorea
angriffe in der straße von hormus
drohnenattacken ob saudische öl anlagen
terroranschläge und kabul ja bietet die
kämpfe in libyen blackout in venezuela
oder cyber angriffe auf ministerien und
stromversorger beinahe täglich erreichen
uns derartige schreckensmeldungen
es ist sehr schwer sich darauf einen
reim zu machen und eine vorstellung von
der tatsächlichen sicherheits und
gefahrenlage zu bekommen
durch ein klarer blick ist erforderlich
um die richtigen vorkehrungen zu treffen
heute in feichtinger kompakt
herausforderungen für österreichs
sicherheit um einen überblick zu
erhalten ist es hilfreich einzelne
ereignisse den großen strategischen
entwicklungen zuzuordnen
hier sind vor allem fünf punkte
anzuführen erstens klimawandel und
bevölkerungsentwicklung die
weltbevölkerung wird bis 2050 auf etwa
neuneinhalb milliarden ansteigen
der zuwachs erfolgte in afrika und asien
und überfordert schon heute viele
regierungen klimatische veränderungen
führen bereits vielerorts zur türe oder
überflutungen und vernichten
anbauflächen viele gegenden sind schon
unbewohnbar zweitens bewaffnete
konflikte jährlich finden etwa 35
kriegerische auseinandersetzungen statt
das wird sich nicht ändern
einige kriegsgebiete grenzen an europa
die meisten kämpfe toben in afrika und
im mittleren osten häufig in regionen
die auch stark unter dem klimawandel
leiden
das führt zur not und elend aber auch
zur radikalisierung und flucht
drittens globale macht konkurrenz der
wettstreit zwischen den großmächten usa
china und russland hat sich erheblich
verschärft sie setzen dabei vermehrt auf
ihre armeen die jüngste militärparaden
und steigende rüstungsausgaben zeigen
europa gerät dabei zunehmend ins
hintertreffen
viertens technische innovationen und
medien
neue technologien und digitalisierung
werden alle lebensbereiche radikal
verändern
vom kriegsschauplatz über den
arbeitsplatz bis zum wohnzimmer erste
auswirkungen sehen wir bereits über
soziale medien mobilisiert man massen
falsche nachrichten erschüttern das
vertrauen in regierungen oder
beeinflussen wahlen und cyber angriffe
legen flughäfen lahm oder führen zum
black hand mit kampfdrohnen werden
präzise angriffe unerkannt und
vollkommen überraschend ausgeführt sie
saudi arabien
wir sprechen von vielfältigen
beziehungsweise hybriden bedrohungs
möglichkeiten
und fünftens politische und
gesellschaftliche radikalisierung
demokratiefeindlichkeit religiöser
extremismus rechts oder links
radikalismus oder extremer nationalismus
gefährden das zusammenleben und die
sicherheit jedes landes fanatismus und
verblendung können zu gewalt und
terrorismus führen erinnern wir uns an
die schrecklichen bilder von
dschihadisten in syrien
was heißt das nun für österreich was
heißt es für uns alle
internationale krisen und strategische
entwicklungen wirken sich vermehrt rasch
und ohne vorwarnung bildwelt aus
kriegerische maßnahmen sind mit den
heutigen technischen möglichkeiten auf
vielfältige art möglich es muss keine
panzer armee sei und es müssen nicht
immer staaten seien die gewalt ausüben
das können zum beispiel auch
terrororganisationen
die geopolitischen rivalitäten können zu
neuen militärischen bedrohungen an den
grenzen europas oder sogar in europa
führen etwa durch raketensysteme
angriffe können auf vielfältige weise
erfolgen oft sind sie ja später camper
oder kommen vollkommen überraschend die
verwundbarkeit von staaten
gesellschaften und wirtschaften steigt
dabei mit ihrer abhängigkeit von
computern und netzwerken
cyber-angriffe können den flugverkehr
die öffentliche verwaltung banken
rechner zentralen den gesamten
straßenverkehr und damit den
nahrungsmittel sowie die stromversorgung
unterbrechen oder für länger lahmlegt
chaos unruhen und proteste sind dabei
vorprogrammiert
politische und gesellschaftliche
umbrüche und radikalisierungen bringen
staaten ist
arge bedrängnis einflüsse können dabei
von innerhalb oder außerhalb eines
landes kommen die anschläge bleiben
weiterhin ein mittel radikaler elemente
um die regierung zu erpressen und die
bevölkerung einzuschüchtern
das risikopotenzial ist somit hoch in
österreich und europa auch weil unser
politisches wirtschaftliches und
gesellschaftliches system sehr
verwundbar ist die abhängigkeit von öl
und gasimporten sowie die digitale
vernetzung unserer steuerungssysteme
bewirken eine extreme anfälligkeit
gegenüber störungen und cyberattacken
ein staat mit seiner gesellschaft und
wirtschaft muss daher widerstandsfähig
sein und die funktionsfähigkeit erhalten
können
vielfach ist man dabei auf
internationale zusammenarbeit angewiesen
denn gefahren kennen keine grenzen
das beginnt beim systematischen
austausch nachrichtendienstliche
informationen sowie die einschätzung und
führt bis zu gemeinsam in
friedenseinsätzen internationales
krisenmanagement schafft nämlich
möglichkeiten krisen vor ort zu begegnen
und ursachen nachhaltig zu bekämpfen
müssen wir uns nun angesichts dieser
entwicklungen führten nein aber gefahren
und bedrohungen sind sehr ernst zu
nehmen denn sicherheit ist heute viel
umfassender zu sehen verteidigung ist
wesentlich breiter zu denken und
vorzubereiten
die unglaublichen technischen und
politischen veränderungen der letzten 20
jahre haben gezeigt dass es immer wieder
böse überraschungen und ungelernte
entwicklungen geben kann
darauf haben sich jeder staat und jede
gesellschaft einzustellen und
entsprechende vorkehrungen zu treffen
der zusammenhalt der bevölkerung das
vertrauen in den staat und das
zusammenwirken seiner organe sind hier
eine wesentliche voraussetzung und dem
bundesheer kommt dabei eine besondere
bedeutung zu